nadav if you're ready um
uh are you ready
yup okay great so you know we're happy
to have nadav cohen here to talk to us
about
um the dynamics of gradient descent for
learning neural networks so take it away
that's a lot adam just please let me
know if at any point in time
there's no problem with the connection
or anything like that
just so that i'll try to adapt so thanks
a lot for the invitation
really happy to be here i will talk
today about analysis of optimization
generalization and deep learning
uh through dynamics of gradient descent
i'll start by setting the stage
laying out the case that i will try to
make today
so um optimization
in the basic
supervised learning setup when we talk
about optimization we typically mean the
process of minimizing
some objectives and loss function in
order to fit
training data and generalization refers
to controlling the gap between the train
and testers
for example by adding some
regularization term
to the objective and optimization and
generalization behave
in deep learning very differently from
how they behave in classical machine
learning
so let's reflect for a moment about that
so classical machine learning not
exactly a well-defined term but you can
think of linear models
svn at a boost things like that
basically we start off
from um the principle of
making our objectives or training
objectives convex okay we choose
uh models in a way that will ensure that
the objective is convex
so typically it has just one global
minimum and usually it's efficiently
attainable
and the choice of algorithm choice of
optimization algorithm that affects the
speed
at which you reach this global optimum
but it doesn't matter in terms of the
which solution you will ultimately reach
in generalization we have the well-known
bias variance trade-off which roughly
speaking
states that if you add on more
regularization
then the gap between train and test
errors uh goes down
that's a good thing on the other hand
the training area goes up
which is a bad thing and vice versa if i
lessen the regularization
then the gap opens up which is a bad
thing but the training area goes down
which is a good thing so there's a
trade-off here and i think
most would agree that we have a fairly
decent understanding
of what's going on here in deep learning
the situation is very very different
we allow the objectives to be non-convex
we give up this requirement
of convexity and now there's not just
one global minimum
there are a lot of them and a priori
it's not clear that any of them
is efficiently attainable but somehow
variants of gradient descent which is
probably the simplest first order
optimization algorithm somehow in
practice
managed to reach one of these global
minimum
and in terms of generalization the
situation is even more peculiar
we pretty much know for a fact that some
global minima generalized well
while others don't and for some reason
on typical problems just to say the
problems that deep learning works for
for some reason gradient descent often
finds a solution
that generalizes well and maybe most
surprisingly is that there seems to
not be a bias variance trade-off the
huge models highly over parameterized
generalized well and even when we don't
exp
impose any explicit regularization the
way we view this
is as an implicit regularization that is
induced
by the optimizer so the optimizer
matters a lot in terms of the
performance of
in terms of the generalization okay
there's not a separation
as there was in the classical case and
most would agree that we don't really
understand
these questions sufficiently well and
the argument that i am
trying to make is that maybe the
language that was developed over the
years
for understanding classical learning
theory maybe that's just not sufficient
for understanding what goes on in deep
learning and in that case
maybe we should look at what goes on
during learning and specifically the
trajectories the dynamics
of optimization the dynamics of gradient
descent
and this is the case that i will try to
make today and i will do this
by analyzing deep linear neural networks
okay so now let's move on and
talk about the actual uh content this is
based on
uh four papers in the last couple of
years
first three were done in princeton with
sanji barora
and students weihu yuping law and
nagolowich
and the last uh papers with my student
norma zine at
tel aviv university so what's a linear
neural network a linear neural network
that's a fully connected neural network
with linear activation
or no activation it's just a linear
mapping
that is parameterized as a sequence of
matrix multiplications
so from a representational perspective
this model is trivial
only realizes linear mappings but
when you run gradient descent over this
model over this parametrization
then you're basically facing a highly
non-convex problem
highly non-complex objective and the
optimization is
non-trivial and neither is
generalization and we will see this
and for these reasons this model is
viewed as a theoretical surrogate for
non-linear uh deep neural networks and
it's really studied extensively
this is just a sample of papers from
last
few years so what we are going to do
is analyze the dynamics of gradient
descent
over linear neural networks and then we
are going to use this analysis to draw
conclusions on optimization and
generalization
so let's start the dynamical analysis um
a technical tool that we will make use
of
is gradient flow this is a continuous
version of gradient descent that's what
you get when you take the step
size to be a infinite testimony small
this is a differential equation if
gradient is sent to these
discrete steps gradient flow would be
this continuous
curve and the reason it is useful
is because it allows you to use various
mathematical tools
from differential geometry differential
equations continuous mathematics
basically and the results that you
derive
can then be translated to gradient
descent with a positive step size
and we're going to see this today and
there's actually an ongoing work on this
generic translation that will be out
soon
so we will analyze and start by
analyzing the dynamics of gradient flow
over linear neural networks the kind of
objectives that we will look at have the
following
structure suppose we have a loss l
over a linear model so this is typically
convex you can think of this as um
logistic loss or l2 and this kind of
loss
induces an over parameterized objective
over a linear neural network
okay which is ph so it's fee at the
point
w1 to wn the value of the objective
there
you want to compute it you just take the
matrices multiply them by one another
and plug it into the original loss okay
so what we're going to study is gradient
flow
over objectives of this form over these
over parameterized objectives
a simple fact that's really easy to um
to see i'm not going to show it here but
please believe me
is that the trajectories of gradient
flow
conserve different quantities
specifically there are
quantities that stay constant through
time and these quantities are what's
written here it's the weight matrix of
layer j
plus 1 transpose times itself the
difference between that
and the weight matrix of layer j times
its transpose
these things are fixed throughout time
and so the trajectories that gradient
flow takes are not just arbitrary they
have certain properties in particular
conserved quantities and this kind of
observation leads to naturally leads to
a definition
which is balancedness we say that the
weights are balanced
if these quantities uh are all the
considered quantities are all equal to
zero
meaning if the weight matrix of layer j
plus one transpose times itself
that thing is equal to the weight matrix
of layer j times its transpose
and that's the definition of
balancedness
and combining this with the above fact
we get the following
result and that is that if the weights
are balanced
at initialization they stay that way
throughout
throughout the entire optimization path
why is this relevant to practice because
in practice
the kind of initializations that we
usually use
are either approximately balanced or
exactly balanced
if we initialize the weights to be very
small then we are approximately
balanced and that's going to remain the
situation throughout the entire
optimization pack
and if we initialize to identity which
is kind of linear
resnets then balance this holds exactly
okay so under standard initialization
schemes uh balancedness either homes
approximately
or exactly throughout the entire
optimization trajectory and this
is going to be very useful for answering
the following
question when we run
gradient flow over a linear neural
network okay over this over
parameterized objective
then at every point in time there is an
equivalent
end-to-end model we call this the
end-to-end matrix
and that's just the product of all the
layer wise
weight matrices and that thing moves in
space
when we run gridding flow over a linear
normal network
and what we ask is how does the
end-to-end matrix move in space
it follows some dynamics what are these
dynamics
they are not gradient flow over the
original loss l because we didn't run
gradient flow over the original loss
we over parameterized and ran gradient
flow
on the linear network so how does the
end-to-end matrix move
apparently it moves as follows if the
weights are balanced and initialization
then the end-to-end matrix follows what
we call the end-to-end dynamics
and this is what's written here the
equation that i'm uh
pointing to right now okay so if you
ignore the blue term here
then this is just gradient flow over the
original loss
l vect means to arrange a matrix as a
vector
so it doesn't matter it's meaningless if
you don't have the blue term here
that would mean that the end-to-end
matrix just follows gradient flow
this blue term that is what encompasses
the fact
that we use the linear neural network
everything boils down to this blue term
and that is a precondition
it's a psd matrix it's a certain kind of
preconditioner
that depends on the end-to-end matrix so
it depends on where we are
in parameter space we have a closed form
expression for it
it's written here please don't try to
parse this i'm just showing it
so that you get a sense that it's not
that complicated
uh intuitively speaking what this
preconditioner does
is it promotes movement and directions
that you've already taken
and more specifically those directions
in space
that those singular directions that have
a large singular value
in the end to end matrix the gradient in
these directions is going to be
stretched
more and vice versa the singular
directions that have
a small sorry a small singular value the
gradient's going to be attenuated
in those directions so if i start off
near zero and i start moving in space
those directions in which i've moved a
lot
the gradient will be stretched more in
these directions so there's some kind of
a momentum effect here
and the relation to momentum can
actually be formalized
bottom line is that if i
add on seemingly redundant linear layers
and then run gradient descent
effectively what i have done
is induced a pre-conditioner a specific
kind of pre-conditioner that promotes
movement in directions uh that have
already been taken
and this result is going to facilitate
um
everything that we're going to see on
optimization and generalization and
we're going to see pretty surprising
conclusions okay so just a word before
we start something that will hint to the
fact that
this kind of preconditioner is not
something that you can
necessarily think of in standard terms
so we have the end end-to-end dynamics
here it turns out that
if the original loss l which we think of
as convex
if it doesn't have a critical point it's
zero meaning if it doesn't have a global
minimum of zero
then there exists no function whose
gradient gives you this
expression here okay this vector field
that means that i cannot write the
end-to-end dynamics
as gradient flow over some kind of
objective
i cannot modify the objective run
gradient flow and hope to get the same
kind of dynamics
it's mathematically impossible okay so
the dynamics of gradient
flow over linear neural network can't be
emulated by
modifying your objective or regularizing
it or anything like that
the way that you prove this is you just
show that the vector field here
contradicts the gradient theorem okay
the gradient theorem tells us that the
line integral of a gradient
of a vector field that is a gradient its
line integral
over any closed curve is zero so we can
construct
curves over which the line integral of
this vector field is non-zero
therefore they cannot be the gradient of
anything
so this is just kind of an interesting
anecdote
what we're going to do now is start
studying optimization and generalization
using the dynamical analysis we will
start with
optimization and before we get to the
dynamical analysis just a word about
the conventional approach or at least
something that until recently was uh
conventional
and that is to look at the geometry of
the objective
and specifically the geometry of
critical points
okay points where the gradient is zero
so there are different types of critical
points
could have a local minimum the local
minimum could be good
meaning that the objective value is
close to the global minimum
local minimum could be bad so the
objective is um
much higher you could have a saddle it
could be strict
meaning that the hessian has negative
eigenvalues
so there are directions of significant
descent or the saddle could be
non-strict so it's very flat
and formally the action doesn't have any
negative values
so a result that was proven
in different flavors by different groups
is that
if you don't have any bad local minimum
and you don't have any non-strict
saddles
so no points like this no points like
this then
basically gradient descent will
eventually converge to global so this is
pretty encouraging right i could
hope to prove convergence to global
minimum just by looking at the geometry
of the objective i don't have to worry
about the complicated interplay between
the algorithm and the objective
and indeed many have looked at these uh
properties
have studied local minima or the
non-straight set or the
saddle property and managed to prove
this way convergence for
shallow models two layers this approach
kind of hits a wall when you go beyond
two layers
if you go to three layers or more even
with the simplest models like linear
nets
if you have three or more layers then
the second derivatives
for example at the origin when all the
weights are zero all the second
derivatives will be zero
so the hashing will be zero and
therefore unless
this is some kind of local optimum then
it will be a non-strict sounds and it
usually is
in this interesting case it is so
property two is just false it's not met
so you can't really go very far with
this approach if you wanna analyze
convergence for
three or more layer models and what we
do is turn to our dynamical analysis
and so this is the implicit
preconditioning this is the end-to-end
dynamics
something that's easy to show is that
if the end-to-end matrix is full rank
then the preconditioner is going to be
full rank as well it's going to be
positive definite
and therefore it will not kill this
gradient
it will not zero it out and therefore
the loss is going to continue to
decrease until
one of two things happen or at least one
of two things
number one the gradient is zero
and then movement will stop the gradient
of the original loss
or maybe the gradient is non-zero but
somehow the preconditioner killed it
and that's only possible if the
end-to-end matrix is
syncing
we typically think of the original
losses convex as i said it's l2 or
logistic regression
um so one the
gradient of this loss being zero that
means that i've reached global minimum
and so i end up with the following uh
corollary basically
and that is that if the loss is convex
the original one
and the linear network is initialized
such that the weights are balanced
and the loss at initialization
is smaller than the loss of any singular
matrix so by going down i'm never going
to hit singularity
under these two conditions gradient flow
will converge to global minimum
okay so i have a convergence the global
minimum
for gradient flow under two assumptions
on initialization
obviously there's no notion here of um
computational efficiency right because
this is
radiant flow it's a continuous algorithm
what we do is translate it to
gradient to set translate the result so
this is the result we had for gradient
flow and now i'm going to
rewrite it okay just same thing but i'll
write it
a little bit differently first of all
instead of saying that the loss of
initialization is smaller than the loss
of any singular matrix i'll say that
it's smaller than the loss of any matrix
that has a zero singular value
same thing and secondly instead of
saying that the weights are balanced
i'll write the definition of balances
these terms need to be equal to zero
and then instead of saying that they're
equal to zero i'll say that their norms
the forbinius norms are equal to zero so
up to this point i didn't change
anything
and now we're going to translate this to
a theorem for gradient descent
and so this theorem specifically we
prove it for l2 loss
can be extended to any strongly convex
and smooth loss
and what we do is strengthen the first
assumption on the missionarization
instead of requiring that the law speak
better than the loss of any matrix that
has a zero singular value
you require a little bit more it needs
to be better than the loss of any matrix
that has a singular value that's smaller
than c
and c is a free parameter that you can
do okay so
slightly stronger requirement and on the
other hand we slightly
relax the requirement for balancedness
we don't require the norms to be zero
they are now allowed to be smaller than
something that scales like c
square under these two assumptions
gradient descent with a step size that
scales like c to the fourth
converges to global optimum
exponentially fast this is linear rate
convergence
it's e to the minus constant times t
times iteration number so for
arbitrarily deep models orbitally wide
models
if you initialize and meet these two
assumptions you will converge to global
optimum
exponentially fast
what can we say about these assumptions
it all boils down to them
eventually and first thing we know is
that they are both
in some sense necessary and that means
that you can't just
eliminate any of them you might be able
to weaken them
but if you throw away one of them
doesn't matter which then it's easy to
come up with canner examples where
convergence fails or
things can even diverge so you can't
hope to throw away any of them
second thing we know is that for the
case of output dimension
one the scalar regression if you use an
initialization that's
similar to the standard one but a little
bit different we call it balanced
initialization
use this then the assumptions will be
met with constant probability
and constant means close to 0.5 so use
this kind of initialization
no assumptions at all probability 0.5 or
more
you will get linear rate convergence to
global option i have a question
um so about the the green assumption
i mean it seems to me maybe i'm
misunderstanding it but it seems to me
like a strong assumption about the
the features or the relation of the if i
think of a standard machine learning
like i have the x i and the y
i if there is some coordinate of the
exercise that doesn't matter to predict
y i
then i could imagine a singular w
that that will be optimal like you know
which would just ignore one of the
coordinates of the x
and so how can you at initialization be
better than this
okay so this is a good question so first
of all if
the scalar regression in the case of
scalar regression
then the end-to-end matrix that's a
vector
and singular means zero so you only need
to be better than zero
so in that case and that's why the
probability is close to half you just
need to follow on the right side of zero
so okay it's
oh i see i get it i get it i okay yeah
yeah yes
yes okay okay so i i think there was a
misunderstanding that okay cool
uh all right so so we have a guarantee
of efficient convergence to global
minimum for arbitrarily deep and wide
models and this is not these kind of
ultra-wide neural networks
it's for efficient models that you can
run
optimize efficiently everything can fit
into your computer and
in that sense it's one of the most
general guarantees that i'm aware of
and this was possible due to the
dynamical viewpoint
we managed to go beyond the classical
landscape approach
what we're going to see now is something
that i think attests even more to the
importance of
a dynamical view and that is the effect
of depth
on optimization and so we're used to
thinking that
convex optimization is easier than
non-convex
that means that optimizing a linear
model is easier than a deep network
what we're going to see is that this is
not always the case
so here's our
end to end dynamics this is in the
discrete time
in discrete form this is the implicit
precondition
and what we can show is that for any p
greater than two
there exists settings with the lp loss
that's a convex loss
where the end to end dynamics reach
global minimum arbitrarily faster
than gradient descent so i can construct
a data set
for any p greater than two with the lp
loss
such that end-to-end dynamics will
converge
as faster as i'd like compared to
gradient descent
and this means that there are cases
where you could
optimize a linear model on a convex loss
okay and if instead you
non-convexify your problem by using a
linear network
you would actually converge much faster
so this is not intuitive
however it's a theoretical result i'm
just saying that there exists
cases like this and the proof carefully
constructs these weird
data sets and the question is how often
does this happen in practice
so for that we run experiments i'll show
here just the most basic one we ran
a lot of experiments this is just again
the simplest one
this is a data set from uci machine
learning repository we use zl4 loss
and this is what you get when you
compare a one layer model that's the
blue line this is convex
you compare that to a two layer model
and a three layer model
these are non-convex and you can see
that the loss goes down
much faster this is log scale on the
y-axis here
and so depth can actually speed up
gradient descent
even when it doesn't give you anything
in terms of expressiveness
and despite the fact that it introduces
non-convexity
in any setting we tried with l4 loss or
lpp
greater than 2 this phenomenon happened
and it also happens with
non-linear mass and we ran some
experiments on that as well
where you take a fully connected layer
and a non-linear match just replace it
by a
sequence of matrix multiplications the
sequence of linear layers
and it gives you a significant speed up
and this idea has
actually already made its way to
practical applications this is from
the past in eurips this is a
state-of-the-art super resolution system
that uses again
won't go to the details of this work
just say that
they use the idea of over
parameterization with a deep linear net
in order to drastically accelerate
convergence
in optimization is the quote from the
paper we found that using a deep linear
net
is dramatically superior and that's
consistent with we see findings in
theoretical deep learning
and so this kind of conclusion that
sometimes non-convexity
helps is something that i don't think
you can do
with the standard convex optimization
viewpoint
and the dynamical approach allowed us to
reach this kind of
conclusion now let's move on to
generalization we're going to look here
at a setting that
where generalization carries a very
concrete meaning and that is
matrix completion we want to recover a
low rank matrix given a subset of its
entries
famous example is the netflix prize that
everybody
knows about so if i denote the
observations by b
i j where i j ranges over some
index that set of observed indices then
what i would like to do
is minimize the rank subject to agreeing
with the observations
i want to find the minimal rank among
all the matrices that agree with the
observations
this is a computationally hard problem
there is a convex
programming approach convex relaxation
and that is to replace the rank
by the nuclear neuron the nuclear norm
is obviously convex
and now what i do is minimize the
nuclear norm subject to
agreeing with the observations
and a result which is somewhat
surprising but well known these days is
that
this actually gives you perfect
reconstruction if
you have enough observations and this if
is important
and we're going to see this a deep
learning approach which we call deep
matrix factorization
deep learning approach to matrix
completion is to parameterize the
solution
as a linear neural net and just run
gradients
and so we parameterize we represent the
solution as a sequence of matrix
multiplications
we don't constrain the rank in any way
we don't constrain the hidden dimensions
so there's no explicit
regularization and we just run gradient
descent over the resulting loss
which is square difference from the
observations
that's it run gradient descent on this
so this setting was uh
studied by gunasekardal a few years ago
they looked at
depth two and what they showed
empirically is that this
often gives you an accurate
reconstruction so there's some kind of
implicit regularization here
and they conjectured that
under the hood gradient descent
converges to the minimum nuclear norm
solution
so in fact what goes on here under the
hood is the convex programming approach
that we saw in the previous line
and they were able to approve this thing
for this conjecture for a very kind
certain specific uh case and we were
interested in studying
the setting when you have depth and in
particular trying to extend the nuclear
norm the proof of the nuclear conjecture
and the first thing we did was run
experiments so we compare gradient
descent
over a linear neural network we compare
that to
the minimum nuclear norm solution so
this is what you see here this is matrix
completion
left plot shows you reconstruction error
right plot shows you nuclear norm
and what you see on the x-axis that's
the number of observations
so every tick on the x-axis is a
different experiment it's matrix
completion with a different number of
observations
and you see here the final solution when
you use a two-layer
linear nut a three-layer linear net and
when you use the minimum nuclear norm
minimization
okay the nuclear normalization sorry
as expected when you have many
observations the minimum nuclear normal
solution is
very close to the grand truth okay
and what we also see is that the linear
nets converge to the grand truth
so in particular they converge to the
minimum nuclear norm solution because
that is
the grand truth so everything just
coincides here
however when you have a small number of
observations the minimum nuclear neuron
solution is
far from the grand truth you can see a
high reconstruction error
and then the linear nets have to make a
choice will they minimize the rank
or the nuclear and they choose to
minimize the rank
and even more so with the deeper model
three layers in this
four layers five layers it's even
stronger um
biased towards long range so the bottom
line here is that empirically it seems
that the linear nets gave up on
nuclear minimization in favor of
minimizing the rank
and this effect is enhanced with depth
so we want to be able to explain this it
seems that the minimum nuclear norm
approach doesn't really pan out and
again we turn to our dynamical analysis
and this is the end-to-end dynamics in
green that's the end-to-end matrix
and what we can show is we can
characterize the movement of singular
values of the end-to-end matrix okay so
we denote by sigma r these are the
singular values of the end-to-end matrix
u r vr these are corresponding left and
right
singular vectors here is a
characterization of the dynamics of the
singular values
please don't try to parse this we will
get to this in a couple of slides
for now just know that we can
characterize the dynamics of singular
values
a corollary of this which is important
right now is the following
if you have depth two or more which
means if it's a non-trivial model if
it's not
just a linear model then
the determinant of the end-to-end matrix
does not
change sun it maintains its sun
and even this seemingly benign
observation of determinate not changing
sign
has far-reaching implications and that's
what we're going to see now
so this is the corollary determine it
doesn't change sign
now consider the following matrix
completion problem
very simple i'm trying to complete a 2x2
matrix i see all observations with the
top left and it looks like this
let's think about the solution space for
this problem and how
which solution you need to go to if you
want to minimize different quantities
so it turns out it's not difficult to
show that if you want to minimize the
schatten p
norm or a chef and p quasi norm this is
a broad class of norms and quasi norms
as special cases that includes nuclear
forbidian spectral norms
minimizing any of them requires taking
the unobserved entry to zebra
if you want to minimize some norm it
doesn't matter which
anything or quasi norm then
the unobserved entry needs to be finite
however if you want to minimize the rank
you actually need to take the unobserved
entry to infinity
because strictly speaking every solution
to this matrix completion problem has
rank 2
but you can approach rank 1 by taking
the unabsorbed entry to infinity
so what you see here is that the problem
entails a contradiction between
minimizing norms and minimizing rank
if there is an implicit regularization
here it'll have to make a choice it
can't
both minimize norms and minimize rank
and the fact that the determinant does
not change sign
means that if you initialized with a
positive determinant
and you fit the observations the only
way in which this could happen
fitting the observations with a positive
determinant is if the unobserved entry
goes to infinity
and this is actually what happens okay
both in theory
as we just now saw and in practice
this is the unobserved entry as a
function of the loss loss gets smaller
unobserved entry goes up this is just a
simple
instance of this phenomenon it happens
in various other cases as well
bottom line here is that there are
settings where the implicit
regularization of linear gnats
drives all norms to infinity so norms
cannot give us the answer okay
so what we do in order to try and gain a
better understanding
is again go back to our dynamical
analysis and specifically the
characterization of singular value
dynamics which is what you see here
the movement of a singular value is
equal to some factor
times the projection of the gradient on
the corresponding singular component
so let's try to interpret this thing
first thing to notice is that
given the end-to-end matrix the effect
of capital
n which is the depth of my model the
depth of my linear net
that affects the dynamics only through
these ground
factors these are the only things that
manifest
the depth if the depth is equal to one
that's a classic linear model
then all the factors reduce to one and
they just they're not existent
once you add depth these factors start
coming into play
and what are these factors i just
multiply the movement of a singular
value
by itself to the power of something and
that's something that power grows with
n so deeper models give you a higher
power here
and these factors therefore they speed
up the movement of large singular values
and they attenuate the movement of small
ones this becomes more and more
significant
the more layers you have so if i start
off near zero
then i'd expect all singular values to
move very very slowly
and then once the singular value reaches
some critical threshold it'll start
moving quickly
and then another one maybe will pass
this threshold and start moving quickly
and i will end up with a small set of
large singular values
and all the rest will be close to zero
so this is kind of a hand wavy
interpretation of what i'd expect and
this is actually what happens in
practice
you can see here matrix completion with
the depth one model versus depth two
versus depth three
each plot shows singular values through
time so with depth one they all
rise concurrently so i don't get a low
rank matrix
obviously depth one is trivial just the
unobserved entries don't move
and the reconstruction error is very bad
it's high
if i add on another layer you can start
seeing the effect of singular values
shooting up
i end up with a small set of large
singular values and all the rest are
much smaller
if i add another layer the effect
becomes much more potent and now
i end up with a few large singular
values and all the rest are basically
zero and so the reconstruction here is
perfect
almost perfect and here it's much better
than trivial
but adding another layer improved it on
the theoretical side
kind of a full-blown theoretical result
we could show it for a simple case with
just
one observed entry we can show there
that
if you have depth one then the
relationship between singular values is
linear so one of them will be a constant
times the other
if you have depth two the relationship
becomes polynomial so
one singular value could be for example
the square root of another
and if you work with depth three or more
then it starts becoming asymptotic
meaning that one singular value could go
to infinity and the second one
will not even pass some finite threshold
so bottom line is that depth leads
to larger gaps between singular values
it leads to a low rank
and this is not something that was
explainable by norms but through this
dynamical view
we can get a sense of what goes on here
and we can get
insights that comply with what happens
in practice
and this idea has also found its way
into practical applications this is a
work by young
[ __ ] in this group at facebook ai from
the recent
nurips what they did is employ this idea
of a linear net
implicitly minimizing rank uh for
designing some kind of um
novel auto encoding scheme you can see
quote rank is implicitly minimized by
relying on the fact that radiant descent
and multi-layered linear networks leads
to minimum rank
and again this kind of insight is
attainable through the dynamical
analysis in places where the standard
view
that we're used to like norm
regularization doesn't really um
pan out so let's uh conclude
to start with a recap i am arguing today
that understanding optimization
generalization
in deep learning might not be possible
through the
lens of classical learning theory and it
might be beneficial to look at the
dynamics
we tried to make the case by looking at
deep linear
neural networks we analyzed their
dynamics and saw the depth induces a
preconditioner that promotes movement
and directions some
already taken and this
allowed us to show in terms of
optimization we derived a guarantee of
efficient convergence the global minimum
this applies to any depth and any width
it's one of the most general guarantees
of its kind that i'm aware of
and more surprisingly we saw that depth
can accelerate
convergence even though it introduces
non-convexity and despite
the fact that it doesn't give you any
gain in expressiveness could still
accelerate optimization
and in generalization we saw that depth
induces implicit regularization towards
low rank that's different from any kind
of norm
all of these results that we managed to
derive
through the dynamical view were
difficult to derive with more classical
um tools as we've seen
and just to worry about the next steps
so
linear networks are nice they're
interesting an interesting theoretical
model
that already exhibits a lot of uh rich
phenomena
but they're not the kind of models that
people use in deep learning
non-linearity
is critical and that's what gives neural
networks to expressive power
and we'd like to go beyond linear maps
so
linear nets correspond to matrix
factorizations
and in this language of decomposing
arrays i can
draw this scheme every node here
corresponds to a matrix i chain
them together and they represent kind of
an effective
end-to-end matrix and this language
allows me to also describe
factorizations of multi-dimensional rays
of tensors
and i can factorize tensors in various
ways i can have a tree factorization or
train factorization
and it turns out that just like matrix
factorizations correspond to linear
neural maps
hierarchical tensor factorizations
correspond to non-linear
neural nets of a certain kind these are
called arithmetic neural nets
arithmetic means that the non-linearity
comes from products
so these are kind of sub-product neural
networks
and turns out that there's an
equivalence here and the
kind of tensor factorization you use
that determines the kind of architecture
that you get
for the neural network if i use a tree
factorization i get a convolutional
network i use a train factorization i
get a recurrent network
and these models are not just
theoretical
uh they also work well in practice okay
they reach for example close to ninety
percent on c4
it's not state of the art not
state-of-the-art but in my opinion
they kind of manifest the power of deep
learning
and it turns out that many of the
results that we've seen today actually
carry over to these kind of models
and specifically something that's uh in
the oven right now and i hope will be
out soon as the dynamical analysis
of gradient descent of these models and
showing results on their implicit
regularization
and kind of a spoiler is that they also
in some sense
minimize a rank it's a tensor rank that
they minimize
and i hope that these kind of models
will um
allow us to reach a point where we have
a deeper understanding of optimization
generalization for a non-linear
neural network and hopefully by that
we'll get closer to the goal of
a deeper understanding of deep learning
so
thank you
okay thanks a lot any any questions for
nadav
are there any um architectures that you
studied that might correspond to like
value networks or tans networks
okay a great question so
yes if you take the
correspondence that i showed in the last
slide between tensor factorizations and
arithmetic neural nets if instead of
tensor of standard tensor factorizations
use something called
generalized tensor factorizations which
is kind of tropical algebra
max plus things like that then it
actually corresponds
it does correspond to value networks so
i do have a paper on that
studying the expressiveness not the
optimization
so i would say that that's kind of the
the next level beyond
arithmetic neural nets uh is to take
this
framework and take it to our value
models
i i don't know about 10h though
but i think values are probably
interesting enough on their own
sure yeah i agree any other questions
for nadav before we take a break
okay well thanks again and we'll meet
back in 15 minutes
for way